vu que je suis une personne un peu
fragile j'ai pas j'ai pas de maladie
mais je sais que je tends beach est
malade et où même le vaccin de 25 entre
la guerre je l' ai jamais fait je cours
je préfère tomber malade
naturellement qu avoir une maladie à
cause de ce vaccin je suis pas une
personne à risque
donc je me considère pas forcément
prioritaires sur les vaccins et donc
j'attends un petit peu voilà un peu
comment ça se passe au niveau des effets
secondaires ne pas avoir un peu l'idée
tout ça tu peux avoir éventuellement à
10,6 tête 5 6 mois avant l'été je pense
que je me serais dit si possible moi je
le ferai je pense d'ici l'été prochain
parce que dans le cadre de mon travail
je suis au contact de beaucoup de
personnes d'âgés et d'origines
différentes donc aussi bien pour moi que
pour les autres oui je le referai sans
hésitation
j'attends de mon tour des jeux
puisque je suis pas dans les priorités
et après ça fait comme un peu pour la
grippe tous les autres vaccins
j'ai été immunisés jusqu'à présent donc
sans souci
je vais voir d'abord ce qui se passe
avant quand même avec les autres oui je
vais
le ferme at il dit que je reproche aux
personnes à risque donc
dès que j'en ai la possibilité oui je le
ferai